Steve: Hi Luca.
Today I have a special guest,
my good friend Luca Lampariello
and we're gonna talk about new stuff,
ChatGPT, AI, artificial Intelligence,
all the different ways that technology is going
to affect language learning. Luca, good morning,
good afternoon, good evening.
Luca: Nice to see you, Steve,
as always. Um, thanks for the invitation.
Steve: Now you being the globe trotter
that you are, where do we find you?
Luca: It's just my place in Rome, you know,
it's just a, my simple place in Rome here. Okay.
I'm gonna be here for a little bit and then I've
gotta be traveling, uh, quite a lot this summer.
Steve: Ah-huh . Um, so we hear these
buzzwords ChatGPT, AI, I don't know, web 3.0.
Steve: And, and then on the other hand, you hear
these people saying, well, technology is gonna
make it unnecessary to learn languages. Where do
you stand on all this stuff? Have you used any
of it? Or are you using aspects of artificial
intelligence in your language learning?
Luca: So, um, I'm using as, as you are
using like the internet in general.
Luca: Um, and more specifically if you ask
me specifically about artificial intelligence
tools, I think at the end of the day, we use,
we've been using them for a long time.
Let me give you an example of that,
Google Translate or Deep L uh, or all these
systems that where you can, for example,
LingQ, uh, LingQ does that as well.
Luca: You just click on a word, behind that,
there's algorithms that process the information
and transforms that information from one language
to the other. So we've been using that. Apart
from ChatGPT, which is the new thing. But we've
been using technology and artificial intelligence
for a long time. Um, now let me tell you this,
as you yourself say in a lot of videos, um,
this is the golden era uh, of language learning.
Nothing... like, never, never in, in, in, uh,
modern history have his language learning become
so easy to actually do, right. So, uh, absolutely.
So I believe that technology is facilitating the
acquisition of any language. Nowadays we have a
wealth of possibilities, but we also have to take
into account that we still learn with our brain.
Luca: Whatever happens when it comes to language
running happens here in our head. So I think one
thing we have to take into account is, uh, you
know, I think we have to educate ourselves and
also educate the next generation to use the tools
that we have for our benefit because, uh, the
internet and also the artificial intelligence
has pros and cons, like everything.
Luca: So it's up to us to understand how
to use it, um, you know, to, to learn languages
better and in general to have a better life.
Steve: Absolutely. And, uh, and we'll get
into ChatGPT. I mean, text to speech, uh,
obviously is an application of,
uh, uh, artificial intelligence.
Um, you know, and I'm on LingQ. If
I click on a word, I can hear it.
Steve: Artificial voice. I wouldn't use
that for, uh, any long period of text.
But if I come across a word in Arabic and
I can't figure out how to pronounce it,
I'll just click on it and I hear it. So text
to speech dictation. Uh, we can use dictation
now on our various. Uh, also just to find stuff
on the internet, you know, find content also,
like I'll find, I get podcasts in the language
I'm learning, and I'll put it on an automatic
transcription website to get a transcript.
Steve: It's 90%, it's not ideal, but it's
better than nothing otherwise. There's just too
many words there that I don't know. Uh, so yeah,
there's all kinds of... and when I, and just get
getting back to what you said about this being the
golden age 50 years ago, before you were born uh,
I would be scouring the bookstores to find a book,
which maybe had a glossary behind each chapter so
that I could possibly read this thing in Chinese,
and every two weeks or month I'd go back to
the bookstores hoping there was something new.
Steve: This was in Hong Kong, and now you don't
have to do that. You just find whatever you want
on the internet.
Luca: Agreed.
Luca: Um, you know, that reminds me of myself
when I was trying to learn, um, English back
in the day, or French, or even Dutch. And
that was like almost 30 years ago. Well,
25 years ago. And it was a different world.
Luca: And I also remember 15 years ago when
I started learning Chinese, even if, um,
I used LingQ, LingQ I have to thank you
for creating LingQ because it's just, I, I
almost learned Chinese exclusively through
that. Now the thing is when, when I was using,
uh, I first used Assimil to get a foundation,
but then I used exclusively, uh, LingQ.
Luca: Now, the thing that happened back
then is that I was not using the, I should have,
I was not using, you know, you can click and you
can see words. What I was doing is I was also
printing, uh, the scripts and then I had this
small vocabulary and I was trying to painstakingly
understand everything, which was very labor,
a very laborious process nowadays, right?
Luca: You can get a, you, you, you can go
on LingQ or you can just download stuff and you
can translate it and you can have an artificial,
uh, you know, voice read it if you want
it in another language. It's amazing what
we can do nowadays. So...
Steve: Absolutely amazing.
Luca: It, it's, it's mind, mind
blowing. Uh, uh, I, I think that
a lot of people do not still know.
Luca: I still believe that. And I,
I, I, I strongly believe that we as educators, we
have to help people understand how to use these
tools because again, I've been, for example,
uh, I was in Bergamo I was invited to Bergamo
in northern Italy and I talked to hundreds and
hundreds of students and they have amazing tools.
Luca: But most of the time, unfortunately, 'cause
I saw it firsthand and I talked to some of them,
most of, of the time, that the time they spend,
not all of them of course, those who wanna learn,
they will learn, but a lot of them are
sucked in this rabbit hole of Instagram,
of TikTok. If I were, if I could go back,
if I could go back to, uh, to when I was 15,
I would learn all the time with these tools.
Luca: It would be amazing. So again,
there's always a dark side to things.
It's like nowadays we have a lot of tools,
a lot of possibilities, a lot of language,
learning materials, for example. But people
still get stuck in the paradox of choice. What do
I choose? They, they're still not sure. And when
it comes to tools, they don't know how to, uh,
use them. There's this, uh, word that I recently
stumbled upon in a, in a French, uh, newspaper. It
was Infobesity or something like that. There's too
much information out there, you know, so, um, yes.
Um, and going back to what you were saying before,
going back to what you were saying before
about using, um, you know, using technology.
Luca: I've been experimenting with this. There's
so many things you can actually do with, uh, a
combination of text, audio, and translation,
and also platforms that can help you, uh,
decipher the meaning of words. So, um, it's just
mind blowing. It has... the, the way I'm learning
languages is speeding up because of this.
Luca: And I see that the people who use
them to their own benefit, they know how
to learn. They're gonna be the winners,
the winners of tomorrow, so to speak.
Steve: Right now, uh, I think there's sort of
two types of learners. The, the people
who aren't necessarily as keen as we
are. And I think for those people,
some of the things that Duolingo has
introduced a certain level of gamification.
Steve: Uh, I know now at LingQ we've got this
sentence review where we have these matching
pair or you have to reassemble a sentence.
And I think that, I'm not sure because
I'm not involved in the development,
but I think we stole that idea from Duolingo,
although we deal with actual meaningful sentences,
but you have to get people engaged at some level.
Steve: So, uh, eventually, of course we want to
be listening to 15 minute podcasts with transcript
looking up words, and we're into meaty stuff. But,
but initially to get people engaged, maybe
the Instagram or the Duolingo or some of
those things are good for giving people, sort
of, instant sense of achievement, instant,
you know, short term gratification that
gets them committed to learning languages.
Steve: would you agree?
Luca: I agree and disagree at the same
time. Meaning that I honestly think to, to put
it in Stephen Krashen's words i, I know we both
appreciate Stephen Krashen, um things like apps,
like Duolingo... now I heard that it improved, but
I'm not just talking about Duolingo. Just think
about flashcards or things that you do that maybe
create that sense of like, give you that shot of
dopamine and you think, okay, I've done that.
Luca: The reality though is that these are not
really, um, acquisition rich envi... like it's
not acquisition rich environment. What do I
mean by that is that if you read a text, just
to give you an example and you have to ask these
terrible questions about what that text means,
right? Or you have to use flashcards.
Luca: You can do that if you want to,
but that is really poor in terms of
acquiring a language. So, uh, again...
Steve: Fully agree. Fully agree.
Luca: So, yeah. The, the problem nowadays is
that we have, everybody's got little time, right?
Quote unquote. And if you have one hour a day,
right? Imagine you have a slot of 30 minutes.
Luca: If you spend 25 minutes toying with
Duolingo, then you have five minutes to listen to
a podcast, then your language is going downhill.
I think we should actually flip, you know,
flip the perspective and on its side and say,
okay, well let's do it this way. If
Duolingo, uh, can help you, for example,
get engaged a little bit, you can use it maybe
in the beginning, um, for five minutes to get
into the session, your language learning session.
Luca: But then again, call me old fashioned but I
believe that fundamentally language learning
happens first subconsciously and then when
we right understand messages and when we engage
in stuff that is interesting and content rich.
And by content rich, I mean, uh, people talking
for example, um, in a podcast. That is great.
Luca: That is one of the things I recommend.
It's one simple rule. Listen to people engaging
in conversations. This is how I learned
Chinese. I was on LingQ and these guys
were talking about super interesting stuff.
The earthquake, uh, in, that happened in, uh,
I don't remember ...super interesting stuff.
Luca: So I was thinking, yeah, this is what I
want to do. It is like engaging with people
talking instead of playing with flashcards
or playing, toying with Duolingo and
everything else. So again, if you,
if I agree, people listening to us want to use
flashcards because they got this dopamine shot,
they want to Duolingo, that's fine.
Luca: But that would be, that should be ten, five
percent of the time that you spend, uh, every day
on language learning. This is my take of course,
but everybody is different.
Steve: Uh, I agree.
Steve: I agree. I agree. Or, and sometimes if
it's structured properly that it's part of, uh,
say a 15 minute interesting, um, podcast
fully accurately transcribed, but you're
able to go into some of those sentences.
Steve: It's also with a thing like matching
pairs where you, you're not getting
it wrong. It's very easy, you know,
it's either right or you can try again, kind
of thing. Easy. No failure, slight effort,
uh, at getting at some of the details, but I agree
with you. It's five, ten percent. That is... gives
me a chance to segue into the subject of ChatGPT.
Steve: So you're making the point that we wanna
engage, I think this is important, even if we're
speaking or writing to people, we wanna engage
with the language in high resonance situations.
So ChatGPT, it's, it's called the generational,
pre-trained text, I think. So what it is, it only
deals with text. So you can't talk to GPT, right?
Steve: But you can generate text. So I did
a variety of things experimenting with it.
First of all, I asked ChatGPT how it applies to
language learning. So, by the way, you can find
ChatGPT on the internet. It's not an app, but you
basically, you know, keep that website on your,
you know, top of your screen there.
Steve: You can go there anytime you want
and ask a question. So first question I asked was,
you know, how does it apply to language learning?
And they basically said, well, you can chat with
the GPT and so you can have a conversation. Not
something I would do. I'm not interested
in having a conversation with a machine.
Steve: uh, and you can't speak to it. You can only
type because it's text-based. I mean, you can,
you know, record it, uh, uh, you know, create
text with a dictation software somewhere else,
but ChatGPT won't do it. So then the second thing
they said, it can correct your mistakes. So you
send in your message in whatever you're
studying, and back it comes correct.
Steve: maybe the only application I see is if
I've got slightly inaccurate transcripts of
something. I'll send it there. They
can correct it. Put in punctuation,
not a big one. The third one was it can provide
you with explanations or examples of grammar. So
I went in, I said, give me 10 examples of, uh,
you know, the instrumental case in Russian.
Steve: Uh, it right away gives you 10 examples,
two of which were wrong, but I'm assuming they'll
get better. Right? Uh, I said get one of the 10
basic grammar principles in Spanish, and one of
them, they gave me 10. Of course ser and estar is
there basic, you know, you can get it wrong. It
doesn't matter really for communication, but one
of them was you have to use the personal pronoun
with the verb, that's wrong, uh, in Spanish.
Steve: Uh uh, and then to me the biggest one is
generation of learning. Like we're thinking
for LingQ, we might like simplify something
that's very difficult so that a learner can
have a first pass through something that's
been simplified and then go at it a second
time with, you know, more words that he has
to learn or she, uh, or say, tell me a story.
Steve: You can go to ChatGPT and say, create a
story using high frequency vocabulary that talks
about a fisherman, and they'll produce a story in,
uh, in, in whatever language in Italian,
and then you can go in there and use that
as learning material. So just a quick summary.
Those were the four things that they recommended.
Steve: And, uh, what's your reaction to
where, where do you think the greatest
application might
Steve: be?
Luca: So I used it a kind of, uh, the way, uh,
the way you used it or the way they suggested.
I've been toying with it a little bit, but my
colleague is doing a lot of research into figuring
out how to do this also, not just for language
learning, but also for production of content.
Luca: For example, for, um, writing stuff that we
want to produce, also for YouTube videos. There's
a, a, a variety of ways in each you can use it.
Specifically speaking about language learning,
I believe one thing that would be
very beneficial is again, um, the
creation of content. I tried it with Serbian.
Luca: I've been learning Serbian for a year now,
and I, I said something like I gave this
um, create a story of an Italian guy,
um, charging to Serbia, falling in love with
an with a Serbian girl, right? And, and, uh,
you have to use 350 words. So it created a story.
Um, and that's fine. I've been toying it with it,
I think, I think, um, I had this very interesting
conversation with a, with another YouTuber,
who's a very good friend of mine, Rocky.
Luca: And we talked about the fact that the,
the ChatGPT is, it can be a great tool, but it
doesn't have to be a substitute, a replacement
for the way we think. Like if we, uh, and
how we think if we rely too much on machines,
then we run the risk of not thinking, uh,
anymore. That's the first thing. And when
it comes to language journey, I gotta tell you,
there's so much content out there, and you can
create your own content even without ChatGPT that
I, I haven't used it that much. I might use it,
but not, not necessarily for language learning,
uh, but for other things I might facilitate
um, you know, some tasks like writing,
some articles, can give me ideas,
but the idea for me is always, okay, give
me some ideas, then I'm gonna develop them.
Luca: So I never rely not even 50%, I just be
it content creation, uh, language learning,
uh, or whatnot. Call me old fashioned. I'm
still like kind of a little bit resistant.
Steve: No, I'm with you.
Luca: Sometimes. So,
um, when it comes to, you know, there's a
revolution coming about, I always say, okay,
well just let me gimme, gimme a second, right?
Luca: I always rely on some very solid tools I,
that I believe are solid tools. I think
it will change a lot of things, ChatGPT,
but I believe that language learning still happens
here. And I think the whole still, uh, thinking
with your own head and using your head to,
for problem solving for content creation,
like everybody's talking about GPT nowadays but
the reality is that with the tools we now have,
with the other tools that the internet provides,
and technology provides in general we can do so
many things when it comes to content creation
and language learning. So ChatGPT might be at
the top of the pyramid in the sense that, oh,
if you want to use it, that's fine, but I'm not
in a rush to use it because I'm learning... I'm
very comfortable the way I use, uh, the tools are
already have at my disposal to learn languages.
This is just my take of course. Everybody...
Steve: I, I agree with you.
Steve: You know, if I go back to
your example of, of a podcast discussion
about an earthquake in China and people,
real live voices and real people, that is, you
know, that grabs you, that's high resonance.
Steve: So, and, and if you told ChatGPT to
create a story about an earthquake in China,
I mean, how interesting is that? It's not
authentic. It's not real. Uh, on the other hand,
if you had to create a press release on something,
you might go to ChatGPT. Again, I'm not sure that
you wouldn't be further ahead to use your own
imagination to create a press release, you know,
that that really meant something to you.
Steve: Uh, and also in terms of grammar,
I mean, I, I asked ChatGPT for, you know,
examples of let's say the instrumental case.
If I Google instrumental case in Russian,
I'm gonna get so many different websites
with explanations and examples, which are
actually produced by people and that are
correct. So I don't have to question whether
this thing from ChatGPT is correct or not.
Luca: Yep.
Steve: So... but it's early days.
It's early days, and I was, uh, learning Korean
and they had an, I downloaded an article from,
uh, ... or some somewhere, and they were
talking about ChatGPT and Naver in Korea
that's coming up with theirs and the Chinese and,
and Bing. And so there's a lot of competition.
Steve: And, and, and the other thing too is
we're getting ChatGPT free of charge. There's
an enormous investment in computing power,
so it's not going to be free going forward.
So it's a bit of a flashy object right now.
And, and there could be applications, but, uh,
we'll have to wait and see. I agree with you.
Technology favors the language learner. It's not
gonna make it unnecessary to learn languages.
I think that's kind of a conclusion.
Steve: We don't know how we're gonna
use each individual example of, of, um,
you know, technology. But technology is coming
our way. It's bringing language learner learning,
you know, closer to us. I think that's kind of
a, a conclusion in, in my view, what do say?
Luca: Agreed. Uh, I, I think, again, I,
I have two, two points. The first thing:
the human being uh, you know, sometimes
people when they, when they tell me, oh,
so you know why you're learning languages in
20 years, you will not need to learn languages
anymore. I think it's BS, pardon my French, in the
sense that human beings right, have, have a desire
to communicate. So there's, you cannot replace a
machine with the fact that you can speak directly
with a human being, um, by voice. That's the first
thing. And the second important thing is that,
yes, of course technology is going to change the
world. The world is changing very fast. Technology
is like stepping up, so to speak. But the reality
is that I believe that we still have to rely on
our brain and use the tools in a savvy way.
Luca: Otherwise technology is gonna devour us.
I, I really like uh, a quote. I don't remember
exactly who said that, but um, when I read it,
it really stuck with me and said, um, screens
devour your time while books feed your mind.
You know? So, uh, you have...
Steve: Very good, very good.
Luca: O o of, of course, I, I like, I like,
we spend a lot of time on front of a screen
whether we want it or not, but when I
read a book, the, the thing that happens
is that really stimulates my imagination.
Luca: And also when I'm in front of a screen,
time changes like you can, you can spend four
hours watching YouTube stuff and then four hours
go by and you realize, oh, I've spent four hours
doing that. While you're reading a book, your
brain is working so much that and your imagina...
it stimulates your imagination that really you
feel like it's feeding, it's food for your mind.
Luca: So I always say screens devour your mind
while books feed it, and you have to find
a balance. It's difficult nowadays not to
spend time in front of a screen. We're doing
it right now to talk, but I believe that a
savvy combination of um... I, I still, I like
saying the books are an incredible technology.
Back in the day when they were invented, it's
an amazing technology that still nowadays...
Steve: The Killer app,
reading is the killer app.
Luca: Absolutely reading is what...
Luca: I
Steve: agree with you.
Luca: Like really it's reading, listening, reading
and listening. This can do, uh, can work wonders
for everyone. So, uh, again, uh, to conclude,
absolutely conclude is just use all the tools that
you have, whether they're digital or not digital,
um, and, and use your head because this is how we
live our life in a, in a, in a savvy, wise way.
Luca: You know, no matter the technology.
Steve: Absolutely. Thank you Luca. And by the way,
we're also gonna have a conversation on
Luca's channel. I'm gonna leave a link
to Luca's channel and we'll be talking about
something quite different. So you won't be,
uh, having to hear the rehash of what
we just had, uh, right now. Thank you.
Luca: Thank you.
Steve: I look forward to speaking you,
speaking with you further. Thank you.
Luca: Thank you, Steve. Thank you.